المياه الوارده من تركيا عبر نهري الفرات
والدجله انحسرت اكثر من النصف منذ اكثر من
ثلاثه اعوام هذه المشكله تلقي بتداعياتها
السلبيه على السكان المحليين في كل هذه
المنطقه
على الفرات العظيم توقف سد التشرين ابرز
السدود عن انتاج الكهرباء اسبوعا كاملا
كمقدمه لازمه شامله تهدد قطاعات الكهرباء
ومياه الري والزراعه التي يستفيد منها
اكثر من مليون سوري بينما على دجله وضع
الضحاره النهر امال الفلاحين ومستقبلهم
على
المحكمه
السدود التي اقامتها تركيا على دجله دمرت
النهر مياهه اصبحت اسنه ورائحته كريهه ولم
تعد صالحه للشرب ولا للزراعه حتى صيد
الاسماك تراجع
حرب مياه تقودها تركيا بصمت سبق وان حذر
مسؤولون اكراد من انها قد تؤدي الى كارثه
في سوريا تمتد بطبيعه الحال الى العراق لا
يختلف الوضع هنا كثيرا عن سوريا فاكثروا
من اربعين نهرا ومجرا مائيا مشتركا قطعتها
ايران عن العراق بينما خلصت تركيا حصص
العراق المائيه من نهري دجله والفرات الى
اقل من 60%
المياه والجفاف اضر كثيرا بقطاع الزراعه
في العراق ابو محمد احد المزارعين الذين
توقفوا عن الزراعه بسبب عدم توفر المياه
للري وهذا الامر ينسحب على بقيه المزارعين
في بلاد الرافدين الذين هجر معظمهم
اراضيهم الزراعيه العالم اضطرت انه
تبيع بزراعه فعلا نطالب وطالبنا مدير
الزراعه وطالبنا لجان مختصه وماكو حلول
لحد الان هسه مدير الزراعه يقول الخطه
السنه نص بنص يعني قبل الخطه كانت كامله
والفلاح ويعاني فكيف هذه الصناع ينص ابن
نص يعني الفلاح راح يتدهور
ايران بنت اكثر من 123 سدا كبيرا ومتوسطا
وصغيرا على الانهار التي تصب داخل الاراضي
العراقيه بينما بنت تركيا 500 سدا مماثلا
على نهر دجله والفرات هذا الامر سيؤدي
بحسب الخبراء الى جفاف هذه الانهار
مستقبلا من بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه